many people ask me questions about stoic
philosophy and practice I've created
this series to provide short answers to
the most common recurring or confusing
questions about stoicism this question
what does a osis mean in a stoic context
is a very good one to ask whenever we're
encountering foreign language terms
being used quite frequently then we want
to know what they mean and I think that
wiki osis has been brought up an awful
lot in modern stoic context it is an
important term in classical stoic
ethical theory although it doesn't show
up that much in some of the texts that
we do have so it's well worth clarifying
what the term actually means and what
its significance is within a stoic
framework
Boyka iosys lexically speaking is a noun
that signifies a kind of action so it's
a noun that signifies a verb which is
also coming from another noun and that
is Waco's in classical Greek Waco's
means house but it doesn't just mean the
building that you might build and then
live in it means the entire extended
family and household you could say all
the people that are involved there so
that is the core idea that then is
getting transposed into a kind of action
what is that action then well it's been
translated in in various ways one is
affiliation or appropriation is another
endearment
I think another term that we could use
is concern once we get to the the
specifically stoic meaning of this term
and all of that should be read into this
it's not an easy term to translate but
it's not an impossible term to translate
either and each of those translations
that I've given
you can work in some situations what
then does this term mean within the
context of stoicism so the Stoics
treated this in a rather complex way and
it's important to maintain a distinction
that I'm now going to introduce you to
that's a distinction between a OSIS as
possessed by pretty much every animal
and then the okay osis that is
particular to human beings as rational
and thereby social animals different
from the other animals within the whole
kingdom of animal life so the Stoics say
that every animal has wakie osis in
relation to itself now what does this
mean it means that they want to preserve
their own life and find the things that
conduce to living well in their
particular way that conduced to living
and and continuing to augment that life
so that's part of it but it also
consists in a kind of self perception a
conception and and grasp of one's own
body in relation to other things and the
Stoics think that every single animal
has this and little babies for human
beings also have this egg that's the
first type and it gets a bit different
when we start talking about human beings
and there's a bit of analogy here other
animals at least some of them do take
care of their their young and sometimes
recognize others of their own kind in
ways that show concern as well and that
would be ok osis it's not Oh a OSIS of
their own bodies but that's ok OSIS in
relation to an other and for human
beings this becomes particularly
important it lies at the very basis of
really all of the relations of affection
or concern or even Duty that we have
towards
other people that we as rational beings
can recognize as part of our nature this
is what allows us the Sochi ability that
ultimately leads to stoic
cosmopolitanism so the idea is that not
only do we have you know perception of
ourselves and a kind of you know
ingrained desire to to remain living to
do it augmenting come to feel that and
even think that in relation to other
beings we can see them if we want to use
the metaphor of the eCos as part of our
own household in stoic ethics this is
going to play a very important role in
some of the authors who discuss it
explicitly like for example Cicero or
Heracles there will be this metaphor of
concentric circles each of them getting
larger and larger starting from the
individual person him or herself and
then you know another very small circle
friends and family and then extending
all the way out to encompass all human
beings or perhaps we might even say all
rational creatures within existence and
the idea that often gets talked about in
terms of these circles is that wake a
OSIS can extend from from the very small
circle where it's very easy to feel it
outward to these other circles this is
something that we can do by nature but
it's also something that we have to
cultivate to a certain degree and it
takes a bit of work so here at Cleese
we'll talk about making these circles
smaller that is a great way of
representing bringing everybody under
one great household and this would make
a lot of sense for for ancient thinkers
because another way of thinking about
the world or at least a civilization was
as a household and
we gonna make a an economy we often
translate that as but you could think of
it as the Commonwealth itself so this is
playing a really major role within stoic
ethics and it raises all sorts of
interesting questions of is this really
selfish or egoist or is it also
altruistic other oriented and the answer
is well it's actually both you it you
end up identifying yourself with other
people who then you come to care about
as if they were in fact yourself so
that's a really key conception to this
this whole idea of wonky osis this is
iosys in the second sense not just in
the sense of being concerned with
ourself and having self perception where
would you go if you wanted to learn more
about this particular conception of way
KO --ss well it does get mentioned a
little bit although not specifically as
such but in terms of other cognate saw
their words that are closely connected
with it in Diogenes Lyra tastes life of
Zeno it's an in book seven chapter one
of his lives of the philosopher so
that's one place to check out
Cicero also discusses this at
considerable length and in good detail
in two works the on them ends also
translated is on moral ends and in on
duties so that's another place to go and
we we also do have this guy here achlys
unfortunately the works that we do have
from him are somewhat fragmentary but he
talks about why chaos is quite a lot and
subjects it to an analysis in his
elements of ethics and on appropriate
ends you'll also find Seneca in letter
121 discussing okay osis but not naming
it as such and if you look at what's
going on in Marcus Aurelius and in
epictetus you'll find them essentially
presuppose
this conception of Hawaii OSIS with
again again not bringing it up by name
but developing the idea a little bit
further so if you really want to see the
term being used a lot Cicero here achlys
and Diogenes Laertes but you can also
find it active within other stoic
thinkers if you found this answer
helpful for you then please share it
with others who might benefit from it
this work is entirely supported by
crowdfunding on my patreon site so if
you find it valuable consider becoming a
supporter at patreon.com slash Sadler